so
bucero
81 that's how we get pirk or modern
defense here, yes that's often
played against me and I always do
n't know what's right. I
often played with bishop B5 and
somehow always had nothing at all or
sometimes less than
NIS directly  E5 ne Willer you do
n't want to play D5 C4
actually well I'll
continue to develop it's not exactly very active but
at least
solid so now we've
reached a typical quiet position that
often arises from such
variants. There aren't that many
game ideas  you can
try a little bit of Dmen flights B4 and so on
and he can be active there. I'm
also doing B4 now so that I
have an idea to make a little progress here. I
think H6 wants to somehow
prepare the offensive here or
maybe  Knight H7 or Knight H5
somehow make it easier now,
definitely B5 n Bishop
A3 which
is ignored so now he has some
trick I don't see any queen E6 he can
try but then of course I
also have the option here and also
to take B7
hm h  Well, moving away the WM knight now
wouldn't be particularly consistent either, so
I'll take it
out. The question is whether you
can really somehow keep the pawn, first
cover it like that and now you have to
think about whether you have a clever
way to keep the queen pawn  B3 no
you can play then he has knight E4
but of course that's a nice
self-chain no yes well the pawn is
a bit too important that you should
just give it up he
's good at it he can play knight D7
ne knight D7 B6 something like that is
true  yes let's see maybe
knight D7 bishop E3 ​​knight B6
and yes well on E3 I think it's
right anyway so we can
move that so now maybe A4 or A4
when it's taken through here hangs
A7 and on tower B7 I have
A5
h or is C4 more clever in this respect
C4 ne because on A4 he can
move A5, make
C4 so on knight C4 I can
simply
tie him up and on queen C4
swap once bishop A7 knight D2 bishop A7
knight simple rook and then bishop
C7 and  it's through yes, that looks good, well, I
didn't find anything great either,
okay, so now
forward like this D D5 is that
possible W then the queen moves, I would have
C6 yes yes okay, that must be good
actually
so that
C5
hm or Queen B5 Queen B5  no it's clearer or
yes it's the
clearest
yes it's actually broken no he has no
counterplay the pieces don't have any
sensible
squares yes yes yes he simply
completely ignored the idea of ​​B4 no that
was probably hard
to lose
no